so Kelly I believe you spent some time  with a recovering heroin addict to kind  of get your head in the right place to  this role what did that give you playing  your role in flight I need it to be  authentic I needed to be truthful about  this role and emotionally find out some  things I didn't know anything about  addiction or heroin I just knew  stereotypes and cliches basically I had  I had some questions and I was very  lucky to find someone who was willing to  share their story because it's so  private personal and different from  every it's like not all heroine addicts  have the same experience of course and  so I got to speak to someone and ask a  lot of questions and it helped inspire  me with about with her journey and you  said they're working with Jones I was  like working with a heavyweight boxer  but what did he mean by that  he's powerful and strong and exceptional  and like to work with him again yeah of  course but I don't know what happened  thank you  you